pour
vous n'avez que moi jean-pierre avec
plaisir lenzi on le savait plus que doué
pour l'antenne lui qui naguère mena la
revue mais c'est d'une toute autre sorte
de plumes qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
puisque avec son quatrième ouvrage en
trois ans justement baptisé comme à la
maison est publié chez plon
il nous expose avec esprit et autorités
des recettes qui l'a naturellement tout
essayé pour lui tout seul parfois nous
assure-t-il
on peut s'en douter la cuisine qu'il
évoque
car c'est avant tout un conteur abondant
parenthèse et en anecdotes avec lui le
concombre reproche le vinaigre agace la
salade devient légende
mais tout cela n'est rien comparé à
l'élaboration quasi mythologique de la
rillette par les soins de ses amis car
mais ce ne sont pas moins de vingt pages
qu'il consacre à semer royal de nos
maisonnée qu'est le pot-au-feu jamais de
chou ni de céleri et c'est un plaisir
quasi gustatif que de l'entendre nous
décrire un poisson roturier comme le
maquereau ou un dessert de tradition
comme les tartes aux fruits vous voyez
bien de qui je veux parler
olivier commenge était formidable
jean-pierre comme d'habitude